I don't know why he did it if it was
because you were scared of what we had
or because you were craving validation
or because you have genuine feelings for
her it was a cruel and disrespectful way
to handle it it was an unacceptable way
to handle it what did you get from her
that you didn't get for me what did you
get from her they didn't get from
[Music]
I think I might eat I'm suggesting um
the food was phenomenal thank you
of course I'm so excited for the show
tomorrow oh [ __ ] um whatever you done
forgot to get chicken
I think it's eerie I am I know oh okay
no worries sorry it's okay
we shouldn't hurry up though if we're
gonna go to Steve's right oh I don't
want to go to that I don't know yeah I
mean either he's gonna be there anyway
Steve Mike Alissa that one dude that
Steve introduces to Adam maybe just
those days let's just not go really I
mean I have so much work to do and I
have to be up early tomorrow
I mean I just feel bad because we said
we'd go you know yeah maybe I should
just go on myself just to show face do
you mind going along oh pretty sure yeah
okay yeah that'd be great
and I can just stay here yeah I'm sure
you don't wanna go yeah
[Music]
Claire cooing yeah sort of
that's up
did you sleep with Adam
it's you
I'm so sorry really really sorry were
you never gonna tell me no I did want to
tell you I thought about it but I just
didn't selfish because it only has loved
us for you to do it in the first place
I know okay I know I was so selfish and
I just freaked out and I didn't know
what to do and I'm so sorry when um like
it was like when you were visiting your
brother right before I moved in together
and I think I was scared I was scared
too but I didn't need to [ __ ] somebody
else just so I can feel better about
myself okay listen can we just talk
about this just let me explain because
it's never gonna happen again okay I
don't care about him I haven't seen him
since I haven't talked to him and it was
just so stupid I think I was just afraid
and please just talk to me
I love you don't don't do that
so what you're just gonna go there where
I don't know it's so late just please
stay here stay in the couch talk about
it
hey just Stan
I love you so much I'm so sorry so what
are you up to tonight I don't know how's
your triple shot macchiato lawyer
girlfriend she's fine
both grunt up to anything Becca and I
were planning on hitting a couple gay
clubs tonight I didn't know you're gay
I'm definitely not straight I have this
theory that there's no such thing as a
straight girl mostly I'm just jealous
you never have to deal with back hair I
mean only my own just me it's a mess
back there I'm sure you wear it well are
you good on everything oh yeah thanks
for all your help please get out of here
oh thank you
[Music]
I mean I heard it got really good
reviews and mom said it was great yeah
but I don't know if I want to watch that
tonight well we can compromise what if
we watch in Bruges tonight and Kings
Beach tomorrow hmm
oh I'm working tomorrow who is it
it's Rebecca it's a scheduling conflict
so she's just switching with Michelle
who's Michelle the new girl that I
worked with last week I'm sorry I've
just been super stressed out lately and
I was like terrible knot in my neck and
you just get it out for me
sure thank you Dad
you just don't know what it's like
sitting at a desk all day I don't
understand what you needed that you
weren't getting for me wish I had a good
excuse
[Music]
and yeah it's not cheating but it's
emotional cheating and that's just as
bad I feel so stupid for holding onto a
lot of her because she means nothing
deserve to feel this way what you did
was not okay trust me I don't expect you
to give me
would you forgive me if I did this to
you I love you so
and I will keep on trying to prove it to
you every day okay
new time
hey man what's up how you doing oh
nothing much just hanging out you know
you know oh you know you want to go out
to a bar or something later no oh no no
it's all good I understand
yeah um no I I guess I'll talk to you
later yeah she's uh she's good too
yeah I'll I'll tell her you said hi all
right all right
yo hey are you doing anything tonight
would you like that new girl that you're
working with um yeah she's fine she
burns the copy but she learned really
how hard is it to make a cup of coffee
oh I was thinking we should go away for
your birthday next month
no no that's so sweet yeah celebrate
death approaching ah I'm just so swamped
this month with this trial do you think
maybe we can just stay here and grab
dinner or something
um yeah yeah that works I just um I
thought it'd be nice for us to do
something fun we haven't gone away since
Marissa's wedding mmm I always have fun
with you yeah I mean that's not what I
meant I just thought we should do
something new let's go to a new
restaurant
it'll be really special yeah that's
that's fine
[Music]
Hey hi I was putting errands nearby he
come drop off the rent check
oh no no no you don't do that I know I
want to know seriously you haven't been
living here well I'm just gonna gonna
leave it right there
he needed thank you
so yeah like looking for a new roommate
any chance are you um really though
I would love to take you to dinner if
that's okay whenever you're ready
of course
yeah so I guess I moved out here about
here ago and I'm really loving it so far
you know I miss the East Coast sometime
oh I'm sorry what
[Music]
[Music]
I'm sorry
hey I'm apologize you okay yeah I'm fine
it's not your fault
hmm
really good bad you like it
yeah Stacy thank you thank you
hmm
this is what you know so I am I started
writing a lot like every day since we
this week good apart that's you're not
like to check it out and you don't have
to say anything back I just couldn't
stop thinking about you
I can talk to you and but I was just
kind of came out there
I know I deserve better I deserve to be
with someone who loves me enough and
respects me enough to be honest with me
I don't deserve to feel this way
[Music]
my god Jeff
how are you
okay
I acted drastically the other night and
I shouldn't have no it's fine it's
completely fine I mean you haven't done
anything wrong you know it's me I messed
it up and I'm so sorry I I wish I could
take it back
[Music]
mean any help
good is the last one oh sorry
[Music]
you okay yeah my shoulders just been
killing me must be working at the
register too much let me get that for
you oh no it's really fine
seriously it's fine that feels amazing
good
so where are we going tonight and I
guess there's this place I've been
meaning to go with I mean I keep trying
to go to I'm excited
[Applause]
[Music]
hmm I'm very excited about watching the
oscar-winning film The King's Speech
tonight I was thinking I could grab food
on my way over
oh um I'm sorry I'm gonna have to
reschedule I'm feeling kind of sick
today okay I can bring you soup or
something it's totally fine I'm just
gonna stay in and said okay I guess I'll
see you tomorrow then
right
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay
I'll be right back
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Jeff
[Music]
[Music]
and I promise to cook us dinner once a
week hmm well I promise to order a pizza
one sweet okay I like your style no I
love it to it you are so beautiful learn
about
[Music]
hey um please calling back I know I know
you hate me right now and I hate me too
I just really want to talk to you
because I know what you saw earlier and
it was nothing I don't care about Adam I
really don't and at the time it just it
could have been anybody I think it
scared me how much I loved you and I
know that doesn't excuse any of it
I just just cost me so much
[Music]
to know what I did
[Music]
and
how are you so sure about me
how did you really know that I was we
wanted to be with
[Music]
how does she really know